on
[Musique]
oh
de manière tout aussi tu parle pas du
tout
12h - yamaha saumon a comme déshéritées
altenach la matière mais voilà au moins
dans cet album on a eu chaud mais je
n'aime pas quand vous aimons tous soient
couverts
mais au cas de ma tv où les quiproquos
hakan yakin faut attaquer les pauvres
comme yellow misako petit ou cookies
tuhaa pae vie
d'amour comme on dit quand même beaucoup
moins geek
bas 6 me et nikon comme à cherbourg des
nations
[Musique]
on a ici navimo quoi pas
chelsea n'avait kouassi dassin
à papa c'est une fois en atteignant pour
lima chambre prenant comme alicia comme
indy
maraghi là qui lie le facilité à tous
les maquis tu n as dû arriver au queen
games li na vi n'a révélé ni eau
[Musique]
nous on aimerait que le gouvernement
voit comment il pourrait conserver
d'abord est protégé et aussi voir dans
quels mécanismes ces bêtes ne pourrait
pas être un danger pour la population
parce que vos mains ils nous sont utiles
à nos populations locales bien que
jusqu'à présent ils nous sont agressifs
mais vraiment nous profitons deux de ces
bêtes
non
[Musique]
je dirais que la population se défoulent
maintenant alors ce que lorsque les
hippopotames attaque était un des
membres de famille voilà le membre de la
famille qui a perdu le sien ce pay pay
ces deux foulées sur les hippopotames